what are the steps to developing and
building a character
yeah developing characters so that's
I think some people have a easier time
with that than others so
I learned this from uh actually a guest
that you had a on your uh show Cory
Mandel like where he he actually in one
of his interviews ironically said
that there are generally as a general
rule two kinds of writers
there are intuitive writers who see
characters very clearly in three
dimensions and they just bleed on the
page and that kind of thing and then
there are more conceptual writers who
are very good at the structure part
personally I'm gravitate more towards
the intuitive side so like and this
comes as a director because uh when I'm
working with actors I can very quickly
pivot into deep backstories and things
like that so for me how do I create
characters it it's a little bit of an
easier task for me but there is a
process that I generally go through
that
starts with me asking like some
questions like
what is
the one thing my character would never
do that's an interesting question to ask
about a character but it can tell you a
lot about who they are so
what would my character never do well
they would never I don't know quit
whatever would never quit Okay well that
that automatically that question can
open up a huge Rich story about why
wouldn't they ever what is it about
quitting that's so pivotal to their core
um
you can also ask and I'll do this what
is one thing they would never say
they may never say I hate you or
whatever uh
now of course you know in the
storytelling realm you would now have to
make them do those things now you know
and of course what would they never say
they would never say I hate you well why
wouldn't they ever say that like what is
it about that word that means so much to
them that they would never actually say
I hate you to another person
it's a way of unlocking
um certain kinds of things
so
that's usually the first step in in that
and then
coming up with what is your character's
major Focus not just as a as a story but
in their life what is it that they are
aiming for
overall like for example I'm working on
a pilot right now and
I'm doing a lot of work on realizing
what is this main character's
drive and this is he's an interesting
one because his Drive is to escape his
past
right because he had a very abusive past
and um
and he is pushing and driving and
running he's an ex adrenaline junkie
he's like pushing the edge all the time
looking for the next thrill
his Drive isn't the next thrill his
Drive is to escape so just going through
and understanding what that is really
also tells you a lot
um
so that's usually where it begins for me
I'll do this little checklist and then
what I like to do
in my perfect designing world all you
know I'm a morning Time Rider so I'll
get up and do my morning routine I'll
take my little hourglass and I'll flip
it upside down I'll start the hour clock
turn off the phone and I'll start brain
dumping I really like the process of
just like
uh just furiously letting my keys go on
the keyboard or notebook too it's a
different method but it's sometimes fun
to just like explore who they are what
if uh
Izzy is just someone who just never
could quite find the right one just
she just tossed and turned her whole
life and just started exploring
um the path as it were of this character
and just digging into their lives and
never correcting anything but just like
going down and even as I'm writing she's
someone that I can never find love no
that doesn't feel quite right
she's someone that did find Love She
Found Love early on but he you know he
ended up leaving her for someone else
and now she's kind of like you know what
I mean like it's this it's complete
immersive exploration into my character
and there's no judgment there's no wrong
stories uh wrong choices here I can
actually go back and edit in real time
but I don't erase anything that's on the
page I just put it all down there
there's something very therapeutic and
really fun in the play of that
um
I like to
I will in life
um as I
could be at the grocery store and I'll
hear an interesting conversation
um like here's a perfect example I was
in a sandwich shop one time and
I'm ordering a sandwich and the guy's
like so you know what do you want I'm
like oh you know maybe I'll take the BLT
okay cool what kind of bread do you want
and I'm looking at all the Breads and
it's this really good Bakery it's just
fair it's a great sandwich shop and I'm
going um
we got a bunch of different kinds of
breads here I've never I don't even
recognized what do you recommend and he
goes oh all our breader made right here
in the shop like you there is no wrong
choice I said oh so you're a sandwich
agnostic then
and he goes
you know who wasn't an agnostic and I
thought oh no oh no no no don't say it
don't say it he goes
our Lord and Savior Jesus Christ
and it was so funny to me that he would
say like he just basically took my joke
that I thought was kind of funny and
just
flushed it down the toilet because
clearly This Guy's super super religious
well there's a great character for a
story someone who is so religious that
they just that everything it diffuses
the fun out of everything
I I have a little note I use a Evernote
in on my phone and I'll like write that
stuff down I'm like oh that's an
interesting character or the I used to
know another guy who would always
whistle and the more stressful things
God he would always
that's such a great little Quirk so I
will keep track of these things and as
I'm exploring what the character can do
when it comes to quirks and things
sometimes I'll look through all this
list of things and go oh yeah this one
would really fit let me
carve this into this person
um
it's helpful too to like
take in the whole person like what how
tall are they how big are they
um
are they are they a ginger or are they
bald or are they you know like just to
really kind of be have fun with
and and sometimes that involves like um
just doing random Google searches or
even Instagram like how you can on
Instagram you can hit the little
magnifying glass thing and it'll just
pop up this random feed of things
you'll be scrolling through and
sometimes you'll see just someone with
the most interesting look they'll have
glasses with a really thick black frames
and their hair is a certain way and they
have black fingernails oh there's an
interesting looking person so that's a
really helpful way it's just like
cataloging all these different people
types that are out there and random
quirks that's super helpful when it
comes to creating characters
um
as it goes and as it develops what I'll
need to do is I I really like knowing
their internet cores their inner what
makes them tick what do they believe
what do they
going back to the what do they struggle
with where are they going in life
um
I like to get more specific about that
as I develop them in the story that kind
of thing but that's generally the
process I know it's not a one two three
step but that's that's usually what I'll
do
to do with that as I go is there a
fictional character that you know you
talked about earlier that one movie that
we all see that if we come here to La
that we've like I want I should have
been part of that and that's what I want
to recreate is there a character or two
where you felt that like that's the
character I don't care if I'm playing it
or filming it or writing it that's the
character
well I can think of a movie that really
hit me you know a closing counter to the
Third Kind was one that really just blew
my imagination
um
the
especially the little kid when he's
because I was really little when that
movie was out but the little kid who was
searching for UFOs like boy I really
identified with that
that one and and ironically around the
same time was when the first Star Wars
came out and Empire
I always saw myself as C3PO I that's
such a strange one like no one
identifies as C3PO but because my
brother was shorter than me and he was
always the annoying little brother like
he was R2D2 and I was c3vo so like
they're such unique characters that's
what they're little
um
antagonistic connection
very much reminded me of me and my
brother and I I sort of loved loved that
uh
and the idea of figuring out how to
create that was really
really fun as especially as a kid to
think about that uh
yeah
Indiana Jones is another one that
he's such a cool character and how do
you make that and
that would definitely be one as a kid I
was definitely like
anything to be a part of the creation of
a process like that you know
the man of Adventure and and ah so good
with the comedic stuff and ah it's so
good it's so good it's so good just yeah